>> Sean: WHO WOULD EVER THINK
THAT I'M HERE?
I WANT TO GET RID OF YOU.
GOOD TO SEE THE PRESIDENT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE ARE FOLLOWING TONIGHT
BREAKING NEWS STORIES.
A LOT TO GET TO DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS HOUR.
WE WERE      BEGIN WITH THE PREI
WE WERE      BEGIN WITH THE PREE
WE WERE      BEGIN WITH THE PRET
WE WERE      BEGIN WITH THE PRE.
TONIGHT, HE WAS IN A CAMPAIGN
MODE.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE BISCHOFF, WHO WAS
FACING AN UPCOMING ELECTION.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, HE THE
U.S. HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES IS
IMPORTANT.
THE MAJORITY, NOT INTERESTED IN
PASSING ANY LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY, SECURE OUR
BORDERS, BOLSTER OUR ECONOMY,
CREATE JOBS.
NO, THEY ARE SINGULARLY FOCUSED,
BACK FROM THEIR LONG VACATION,
ON ONE THING AND ONE THING ONLY.
THAT'S DESTROYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ANYBODY WHO
SUPPORTS THEM.
THEN WE'VE GOT JERRY NADLER, YOU
KNOW, THE GUY FROM NEW YORK
WHO'S SUFFERING FROM IMPEACHMENT
DERANGEMENT PSYCHOSIS.
HE JUST DIRECTED HIS JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO TAKE THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE NO HIGH
CRIMES, NO MISDEMEANORS.
THERE IS NO JUSTIFICATION AT
ALL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IT WAS A
COMPLETE UTTER FAILURE, DOUG.
ROBERT MUELLER'S TESTIMONY WAS
POINTLESS.
LET ME HELP NADLER OUT.
IT WOULD BE TOTALLY DISMISSED.
BY THE WAY, DEMOCRATS IN THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT VOTED FOR TRUMP,
YET THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE
THAT EITHER.
JUST A PRODUCTION.
BASICALLY, DEMOCRATS ARE WASTING
YOUR MONEY, WASTING YOUR TIME,
AND DO NOTHING TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOTHING.
IT'S BEYOND PATHETIC, IT'S AN
ANTI-CLIMATIC, CULMINATION OF
DIRTY POLITICS.
IT ALL STARTED AT THE VERY TOP.
THAT WOULD BE PRESIDENT OBAMA,
JOE BIDEN.
BREAKING TONIGHT, JUST NOW,
JUDICIAL LODGE UNCOVERED A NEW
TROVE OF DOCUMENTS SHOWING HOW
OBAMA'S STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS WERE DESPERATELY
TRYING TO UNDERMINED
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP IN 2016.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE NEW
DOCUMENTS.
ACCORDING TO THESE MATERIALS,
THESE OFFICIALS ALLEGEDLY
DISSEMINATED RAW INTELLIGENCE AS
ILLEGAL.
ANOTHER CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
THREE ANTI-TRUMP SENATORS, ALL
IN AN ATTEMPT TO PROVE COLLUSION
THROUGHOUT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
SOUND FAMILIAR CUSTOMER IT
SHOULD.
AFTER HILLARY CLINTON'S DOSSIER
WAS PASSED AROUND.
REMEMBER, IT WAS WEAPONIZED BOTH
BEFORE AND AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION.
THE REAL QUESTION MUST BE
ANSWERED.
WE'VE GOT TO GET TO THIS POINT
PEERED WHAT DID OBAMA, WHAT DID
RICE, WHAT DID THEY KNOW.
AND ALSO, WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT?
REMEMBER, WE'VE BEEN TELLING